okay Kanye running for president um um
okay here's the thing there are two
things going on here one thing is why he
would do it the other thing is if it's a
good idea so let's discuss why he would
do um
first of all I don't know how I got
through this whole podcast with that
giant [ __ ] pimple man you said it
ring it up cuz I want him to be all
self-conscious about the whole every
tiny so I think that should gonna shoot
all over the [ __ ] YouTube class when
I was focusing on his solo I'll just
like you said now you good SATs are you
good just don't know he said okay all
right okay so uh here's the thing I
completely understand why Kanye would do
it because everything Kanye has ever
done his entire life he's been told he
can't do it and that he did it and that
essentially lends itself to a way of
thinking which is oh [ __ ] I can do the
impossible there is nothing that can
stop me and I started thinking about
what if he was gonna run for president
again we're not talking antagonize some
mental health issues and that's the most
dangerous because you don't need him
getting all emotional and going I miss
the old Kanye like that could be no more
Iran Kanye yeah you know I mean like we
can't have you by that the button we got
Trump in there like yeah but he's not
his mental health isn't as shaky as
kindness I think there's a big problem
when you have that okay so that being
said I think Kanye is the type of person
if it is great at HR in other words like
when Konya want to learn about fashion
he was like I won't just intern at Louis
Vuitton or one of these like big fashion
assets you just want to learn people
that want to learn and want to like soak
up information these are the types of
people that you wanted leadership roles
right so he finds Virgil I'm Virgil was
out there he was very good but he plucks
original he puts him under his wing and
he lets Virgil help him build this
brilliant brand right
I think that he's great at locating
talent and finding talent obviously
sometimes you're gonna have a Timmy
Timmy Turner or whatever the [ __ ] that
guy's name was designer right but like I
think Kanye is good with talent and I
think he would find and hire the talent
that would help him effectively run a
business or country if he was going to
do it it's the emotional yes is he very
easily manipulated yes and that would be
the trickiest thing you can manipulate
him into do anything if you just seem
smarter than anybody smarter than Kanye
can get Kanye to do anything
if they're in the same room that's my
feeling and that's why it's tough when
you're what for him to be president for
him to be president that being said a
completely understand why he thinks he
could do it I really do I talked to my
my brother-in-law who's like a big Kanye
fan he's like honestly man I just hope I
don't vote for him because he loves them
that much yeah people are gonna beat you
will get votes dog son oh my god so
first thing that comes to mind is this
is just marketing for his new music
because he dropped a song a day before
he knows this I think it's just
marketing a new music coming out hey
let's have people talking about me I
have a picture with you on Maz Elon Musk
says he supports me like this is I think
it's just about music second there's a
conspiracy theory that he's helping
Trump I've heard this by him running
he's gonna take away some of the black
vote from Biden and that will seal the
deal I'll take away the black vote from
Trump any black votes Trump what I got
not saying there would've been a lot
I think they don't look at Connie oh
this is black Trump yeah but I mean
right now Biden has more black support
than shrunk course me and Kanye is gonna
get from both sides mark thought yeah
I've heard like the same conspiracy I'm
not really sure it's either a PR stunt
or he's trying to like pull votes for
Trump I think probably PR stunts
yeah the it's PR stunts I'm with you on
that but that's another good discussion
which is who does this hurt more I think
it hurts Biden more yeah you think so
absolutely I think that there are black
people and white people that are so
influenced by Kanye and he has such
devout fans I mean like cry at the
[ __ ] concert type fan it's true young
black people gonna vote for Connie over
Biden probably a hundred percent you
know there's a thing everybody's been
knocking Trump which is fine knock them
all you want I haven't had a single seen
a single person support by them there is
no movement which is Biden is our next
hope Biden is a the movement is not
Trump is our hope because Biden's not
the guy you wanna know some thought that
I think just happened
look you know how the key should Lance
Bottoms the Atlanta mayor she was
gaining tons of popularity she was
popping you think that gave me that Cove
it I don't think she has Kovac I think
that they may get fake kovat test
fake Kobe positive or they gave her Cove
it but I think that they they said you
are not going to be vice president
you're getting too popular
it's not your job we want that Club
achar [ __ ] and I would not be surprised
if they start giving Cove it or the
people that are going to be it's either
Kamala or Klobuchar whoever's willing to
kiss the ring I would not be surprised
if the other people the Stacey Abrams
the other people who were like close to
a conversation end up getting Cove it
would not be right and isn't that a
great thing to do because you can't risk
by his old ass getting caught Korona cuz
he's out of here if he gets it talking
about too much this week of it I'll just
say you better your conspiracy he gave
up on you you was right so he was right
yeah it's too different yeah and it was
like not so much take a different over
here yeah no apparently Kanye missed the
ballot deadlines already in Texas New
York and Illinois which is his home city
Chicago
it's obviously [ __ ] and it's either
to split votes but I don't even think
he's I don't think Trump would do that
like I don't think Connie is that much
of a tool to try to pull votes from
anyone sir what do you mean he is
pictured with him there right then
Connie's not powerful enough for Trump
to be like yeah do me this favor what it
what did we talk about earlier this is
the most important thing for this
discussion what do we talked about
earlier mark what did you say before you
put someone a position of power they
need to be tethered to you hmm
I think that Kanye is too emotionally
unstable
to be tethered and if that's the case
he's decided to [ __ ] to go on TV
and go George Bush don't care about
black people he's he's a person attacked
the establishment like that if there was
a conversation where Trump goes yes I'd
like you to take some black votes away
so watch you run and then maybe you'll
get something we could peel some way
from Biden
I've been con Yenny type of [ __ ]
that might get upset at Trump one day
and go nah we had a conversation and he
told me to run and take black votes away
from Biden connie's the type of
[ __ ] to say that [ __ ] remember
when you were like yo they put hits out
on me yes I agree with Tom Trump I would
never trust Kanye to keep a secret or I
do some on the table but at the same
time
Trump is desperate right now so I can
also see Trump be like yo I've worked
with Kim Kardashian already I'll have a
little position for her or whatever if I
get reelected I could see that Kim and I
could see Kim being the one to commit
but Trump can I have or any Trump's
people can I have every conversation
with Kanye cuz I should gonna come out
it's probably in a song it's gonna be on
a t-shirt I'm up for go love to squeal
bro
[Applause]
you